se dan los siguientes números iniciales
y las reglas para dos sucesiones tenemos
la sucesión en x la asociación en jeff
la asociación en x inicia con el número
1 lo colocamos y dice que en cada una de
los siguientes términos sumaremos 2
así es que coloquemos la asociación de x
el primer término será 1 el segundo
término sumar a 2 así es que uno más dos
es igual a tres y el tercer término será
tres más dos igual a cinco por otro lado
la asociación y nos dice que el número
inicial será 2 coloquemos lo de una vez
la regla nos indica que en cada término
sumaremos 4 así es que el segundo
término será 246 y el tercer término 64
vamos a graficar esto hagamos un poco de
espacio
tenemos entonces equis y donde tiene
distintos valores lo que haremos es
tomar equis y llevarlo al eje de las
equis que es este eje horizontal
y los valores de hielos tomaremos sobre
el eje de la ley que es este eje
vertical empecemos entonces cuando x
tiene el valor de 1 que tendrá valor de
2 así es que vamos a tomar este primer
punto y llevemos x a 1 con el valor de y
en 2
x horizontal 1 y vertical en 2
el segundo punto será cuando x tenga el
valor de 37 tendrá el valor de 6
llevemos x en nuestro eje horizontal a 3
aquí está el 3 y cuando x vale 3 valdrá
que subimos
a este punto d
finalmente tomaremos x con el valor en 5
aquí está el 5 y ya tendrá valor de 10
cuando x tenga valor de 5 así es que
iremos hasta el lugar de 10 en 10
bien 10x en 5
vamos a ver nuestra respuesta y nos dice
los términos en la sucesión
son cuántas veces los términos de la
asociación x y por esto podemos ver la
relación entre x y jeff si nosotros
vemos la relación de x con llevemos que
x es igual a uno cuando es igual a 2
podemos ver que es el doble si x es
igual a 3 el doble es 6 se cumple la
misma regla y cuando 5 es el valor de x
10 es el valor de y podemos ver que 10
es el doble de este 5 por lo que podemos
decir que ya es dos veces
el valor de los términos en la
asociación de x vamos a comprobar
nuestra respuesta
y es correcta